he was one of the most powerful men in
politics but John Bercow former Speaker
of the House of Commons is under
pressure and his entry into the House of
Lords hangs in the balance
amid claims he bullied staff now Sky
News can reveal to more people are on
the verge of submitting formal
complaints after Lord Liz vane wrote to
Commons bosses on Monday those who
worked closely with him are calling for
more people to speak out he brutalized
staff in the House of Commons and
elsewhere might include myself in that
and I think he brutalized is a good word
for what he did to Lord less pain his
private secretaries they have all told
me in private moments and some of their
experiences at the hands of John Bercow
my view is that he brutalized people
I've never seen anybody in my entire
life
treat anybody as badly as John Bercow
treated regularly the people around him
bullying allegations against mr. Berko
have been made before and there is
frustration and hurt among those who say
MPs didn't do enough anybody who was
speaking out about it was the previous
speaker was in place really received a a
cold wall of silence and I speak from
personal experience myself because when
the Cox report came out I directly
challenged the speaker on the floor of
the House to consider his position which
was received with a very very difficult
response for me to deal with and clearly
it's something that other members have
experienced as well sources close to the
vetting process for new peers believe
any investigation into John backhoes
behavior could delay or potentially
prevent his membership of the House of
Lords and with one complaint already and
the potential for two more the
likelihood of that investigation only
increases mr. Barco declined to be
interviewed by Sky News today but
speaking on election night he denied all
allegations of bullying against him I've
never bullied anyone in any way to any
degree in any situation at any time
I assured a straightforward rebuttal it
is not true but those who feel wronged
by him want his peerage paused and the
claims investigated fully if John Bercow
gets a peerage now people are just going
to stare at that
in disbelief with incredulity and the
reputation of Parliament will be
traduced I think it would be a scandal
which Parliament would struggle to live
down while mr. Berko continues his life
after Parliament becoming a professor of
politics at a London University today
difficult questions remain for
parliamentary authorities both about the
past and the future - Kate McCann Sky
News